-House Republicans
are possibly on the verge
of making Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan,
one of the key players
in the January 6th coup attempt
and a hard line MAGA extremist,
the next Speaker of the House,
even as Trump himself
was just hit
with his second gag
order by a judge.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
House Republicans still don't
have a Speaker
after two weeks of humiliating
infighting chaos.
Let's check in
on their party's leader,
the faraway frontrunner
for the 2024 GOP nomination,
Donald Trump.
I mean, there's no way things
could be going worse for him
than they are
for House Republicans, right?
-Breaking news here
in Washington --
District Court Judge
Tanya Chutkan
has issued a narrow gag order
on former President Trump
and the other co-defendants
in his D.C. election case,
prohibiting all parties
from targeting
Special Counsel Jack Smith,
federal prosecutors,
or court staff.
-Judge Tanya Chutkan said
from the bench that Mr. Trump
is now prohibited
from reposting any statements
publicly targeting
the special counsel,
his staff, the judge's staff
or court personnel,
and also witnesses
to the extent
that it involves their role
in the case.
-That's right.
Trump is prohibited
from posting statements
about the special counsel,
his staff,
the judge's staff, witnesses --
and here's where it gets
worse for him...
By the way, this is now
Trump's second gag order,
after he was already
slapped with one
for a civil fraud trial
in Manhattan.
If he keeps getting hit
with partial gag orders
from all of his court cases,
his social media posts
are just going
to look like this.
Now I don't need to tell you,
we live in turbulent times,
and times like these,
you need leadership.
Democrats have Joe Biden
in the White House,
Chuck Schumer in the Senate, and
Hakeem Jeffries in the House.
Say what you will about them,
and there is plenty
to criticize,
but at least their status
as leaders is stable.
Now let's compare that
to the GOP leadership.
Likely 2024 nominee
Donald Trump,
whose current top four suggested
Uber destinations
are courthouses.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell,
who can often
be found buffering.
And the Speaker of the House,
which is currently held by
Interim Speaker Patrick McHenry,
who, knowing the job
isn't permanent,
is banging every gavel
like it's his last.
[ Bang ]
Impossible to prepare
yourself for it.
The Republican Speaker fight
has been a roller coaster,
and not a good one.
I'm not talking Kingda Ka,
where you're laughing
with your buddies, screaming,
"Oh, my God,
I'm going to puke."
I'm talking about
one of those real old ones,
the kinds they have
at county fairs
where the seat belt
looks like it came
from an '84 Ford Escort,
and you get strapped in
by a dead-eyed
17-year-old
who reminds you both to keep
your hands inside the vehicle
and to make peace
with whatever God you pray to.
And as you make the first climb,
you look into the footwell
and you see three loose screws
and a human ankle bone.
Where you think, "Oh, my God,
I'm going to die.
I'm going to die listening
to a Jason Aldean cover band."
And if you do survive afterward,
you check out the photo
they took and you end up
looking like this.
Good news, you guys.
Good news.
If we use that picture
two more times,
I get a free footlong at Subway.
Bad news,
it's their new Rudy Sandwich,
which is just two pieces
of bread
and a bunch of [bleep] nuts.
Now here --
here is a quick recap
of what's happened
over the last two years --
I'm sorry,
I meant the last two weeks.
-Kevin McCarthy practically
daring hardline Republicans
to come after him.
-If somebody wants to make
a motion against me, bring it.
-To which Gaetz responded,
"Just did."
-He says he's coming for you.
Can you survive?
-Yes. I'll survive.
-The Speaker of the House has
been removed from his position.
-Some House Republicans
have been in contact with
and have started an effort
to draft former
President Donald Trump
to be the next Speaker.
-On Capitol Hill right now,
we have breaking news.
House Republicans have nominated
Steve Scalise moments ago
as their new Speaker.
-I want to thank my House
Republican colleagues
for just designating me
as the Speaker.
-Just hours after being
nominated to become
the next Speaker of the House,
Congressman Steve Scalise
says he's dropping out
of the race.
-I'm withdrawing my name
as a candidate
for the Speaker designee.
-Another round of votes
have just been had,
And now Jim Jordan is the new
Republican nominee for Speaker.
-Right now, it looks like
the party's newest nominee,
Representative Jim Jordan,
get this, does not have
enough votes
from his own GOP colleagues
to win the speakership.
-I would call House Republicans
a cluster [bleep],
but a cluster implies
some sense of unity.
They're more -- they're more
like a scatter [bleep].
I've seen more organized
groups of seagulls
fighting over a potato chip.
"Whoa, whoa, fellas.
Let's just cast our ballots
in an orderly fashion,
and whoever wins
the most votes gets -- Dorito."
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
You got to --
you got to remind me
to listen to that seagull tape
before we do the show.
[ Imitating seagull ] What?
"Don't worry, Sal,
I can do seagull. Oh-oh."
I swear to God, if they didn't
have the House to work in,
I'm not sure half these guys
could find a house to live in.
You'd just see a pack
of feral Republicans
wandering through the woods,
arguing about which hole
to [bleep] in.
"Hey, that's my hole.
I found it first!"
-Usually, a political party
trying to gain power
in a democracy
wants to project competence,
even if they have to lie.
But Republicans are so mad
at each other,
they're just going on TV
every damn day
telling American people,
"We suck."
-Funding the government is
part of our fundamental duty,
and we can't even do that.
So, and now here we are at the
11th hour, with a clock ticking,
and we can't even
seat a speaker.
Man, that says volumes.
At first, it was
somewhat comical.
Now it's on -- it's bordering
on the on the absurd.
-This is not responsible.
We need to elect a Speaker.
-This is petty. This is petty.
And I'm getting
freaking tired of this.
-People are looking
for a perfect system?
Well, they shouldn't be looking
at the US House right now.
-How does that
make you guys look?
-It makes us look like
a bunch of idiots.
-No, don't worry.
You did already look like
a bunch of idiots,
literally.
South Carolina Congresswoman
Nancy Mace wore the "A"
on her shirt
for "The Scarlet Letter,"
apparently not having
read the book.
Wyoming Congresswoman
Harriet Hageman
brought a lasso
to a GOP meeting,
hoping to finally catch
one of them Duke boys,
and Jorge Santos
wore a suit jacket
over a fleece
over a shirt and tie,
a fashion crime more heinous
than any of his actual crimes.
Politicians spend
millions every year
taking out ads to convince
people they should be in charge,
while Republicans are going on
national TV every day for free,
telling people
"For the love of God,
do not put us in charge."
Do you know how rare that is?
That's like our cue card guy,
Wally,
saying he doesn't want
a line in the show today.
Are you sure, Wally?
Because you do still get paid
extra if you say a line.
-Eh.
-Okay, but for real though,
bits aside,
how would you solve
this mess in Congress?
-Well --
-[ Shouts ] Doesn't count.
[ Laughter ]
The infighting has
gotten so bad,
one Republican member
of Congress just came out
and said what many
have long suspected
about a large portion
of the Republican Party --
they don't actually
want to govern.
-It's a tough scenario,
but there are people in there
that are honorably trying
to get to the right place,
and then there are people
in there, as you know,
that like to go on the TV
and are not necessarily
negotiating for anything
other than TV time.
-These guys want to be
in the minority.
That's exactly --
I think they would prefer that
because they can just vote no
and yell and scream
all the time.
-Yes. That's the whole party
in a nutshell right there.
They were Little League
parents screaming at the umpire
through the chain link fence,
drunk on Thermos wine
at 8:30 a.m. on a Saturday.
But now they're the umpire,
and it's a lot harder
to be the umpire.
You have to crouch
for three hours,
keep track of balls
and strikes.
Then every now and then,
this happens.
-Hits the 0-1.
Oh!
-Oh, no! Got the umpire.
-Don't worry.
The umpire didn't die.
He just wanted to.
Can we see what his face
looked like under the mask?
[ Laughter ]
Republicans like yelling
and screaming
so much more
than governing,
they looked across the country
at all 300 million Americans,
picked the loudest screamer
and said, "Yeah,
let's make that guy
the leader of our party."
A guy who screams so much,
he's now under two gag orders
and still won't shut
the hell up.
The guy who does all his press
conferences right next to a 747
just to prove he can
out-yell a jet engine.
But that really is
the truth right there.
Republicans are not
a serious governing party
because they don't have
a serious governing agenda.
They don't even
have serious options.
With each failed attempt
to pick a Speaker,
Republicans don't get together
and say, "We need to do better."
They say,
"We need to do worse."
And nothing exemplifies
that more than the fact
Republicans have moved
on to Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan,
a MAGA extremist
who tried to overturn
the 2020 election
and played a key role
in the January 6th coup attempt.
-Jim Jordan scored former
President Trump's endorsement
early this morning,
which should come
as no surprise.
Here is Jordan in Harrisburg,
Pennsylvania,
attending a Stop the Steal rally
two days after Election Day.
In the weeks and months
after that,
Jordan went on various
right wing media outlets,
where he attempted to sow
distrust in the 2020 election
and made baseless claims
of election fraud.
Jordan's name appears
throughout the bipartisan report
from the House Select committee
investigating January 6th.
The report says
that Jordan attended
numerous post-election meetings
with senior White House
officials and Rudy Giuliani,
discussing how to challenge
the election results.
-Even if you put aside
the attempted coup
and Stop the Steal rally,
I think anyone who spends
any time in a meeting
with Rudy Giuliani
should be
automatically disqualified.
Unless that meeting
is an AA meeting,
although if you told Rudy
to go to AA,
I guarantee you he'd show up
at an American Airlines flight
with AA batteries.
And that was today's joke
about Rudy
mixing up places and things.
♪♪
-America!
Even as Mike Pence, who,
as you may recall,
and -- [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates seagull ]
Better?
Even Mike Pence, who, as you may
recall, and as he maybe doesn't,
almost got killed by the mob
on January 6th,
had decided to back Jim Jordan,
despite the fact that Jordan was
on the side of the mob
and tried to sway Pence
to overturn the election.
A CNN anchor pointed that out
in an interview with Pence,
and his answer
was predictably spineless.
-Jim Jordan would be
an outstanding
Speaker of the House.
The American people want to see
the Republican conference
come together,
elect a speaker,
and get back to work.
-Well, it's interesting to me
to hear you say that
Jim Jordan would be
a great speaker,
given he was someone
who sent a text to the chief
of staff on January 5th
that outlined for you
to violate the Constitution
and block the certification
of the election.
I mean, do you really believe
that's someone
who should be third in line
to the presidency?
-I have immense respect
for Jim Jordan.
He's a man of integrity, and
I've known him for many years.
I was not aware
of his opinion
going into January 6th --
-So that doesn't bother you?
-My interaction with
Congressman Jordan in December
was simply over
the legitimate objections
that members of Congress were
permitted to file under the law.
-"Of all the people
who fomented a violent mob
intent on murdering me,
there is none I consider
a better man than Jim Jordan.
It would be an honor to be
murdered by him." [ Laughs ]
Pence's problem is there are
no other options.
Here's a perfect example.
Republican Congressman
Dan Crenshaw
made the case for Jim Jordan
to CNN's Jake Tapper,
who pointed out that,
unlike Crenshaw,
Jordan pressured Pence
to overturn the election.
And Crenshaw basically said
if that disqualified him,
there wouldn't be anyone else.
-I'm supporting Jordan.
I'm going to vote for Jordan.
-I mean, he defied
the congressional subpoena,
and he was trying to get Pence
to overturn the electoral votes.
But anyway, you're -- you're --
in the --
you're in the Jordan camp.
-But a lot of them did that.
If I held that grudge,
I wouldn't have friends
in the Republican conference.
-Right, that two-thirds of --
-That's a lot of them.
-That's two thirds
of the conference.
That's an excellent point.
-I was on an island there.
-Yeah, I hear you.
-I love how they're both
laughing off
that deeply depressing fact.
But it is a fact.
There are very few Republicans
who didn't try to overturn
the 2020 election at this point.
Being a Republican
who thinks Biden won
is like being
a vegan zombie --
"Do you have anything
other than brains?"
That is the core
of the modern GOP.
It's not a serious
or competent party
that can be trusted with
the responsibility to govern.
As far as anyone can tell,
their only discernible position
is that January 6th was good,
and anyone involved in that,
whether it's Jim Jordan
or Donald Trump,
should be in a position
of leadership.
Their pitch to the American
people is,
"Elect us because we're a..."
-Bunch of idiots.
-This has been A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]